[Music]
you know you only live once and I'm a
huge fan of her music and she was a fan
of me and her team was a fan of me so it
was a great experience
alive even when I saw the video I was
like oh yeah wow same reaction I can see
you guys collaborating together would
you ever do that with Nikki yeah 100
she's I think arguably the most talented
female rapper ever she's done so much
for women in that business and we got
along great so 100
[Music]
I like to see the super freaky girl
movie
I think would definitely be rated R but
that'd be an interesting one and Nikki
agrees retweeting our interview the
queen of rap writes in part OMG he was
so dope I def do a movie with him but
for now Alexander is focused on his
music career
[Music]
Highway 99 congratulations on your debut
album
has a sunk in that it's out there now
the first real experience I feel like
I've had was playing in Calgary there's
like a thousand people there and I
didn't know how I was going to be
received Alex right here please you see
so many actors and musicians going kind
of back and forth and I just wanted to
come from a place of authenticity and
the crowd was nuts
I never could have expected that in my
wildest dreams
tomorrow
morning
music especially as a kid was my therapy
you know whenever I was dealing with
stuff as a kid that would be my outlet
what has been your most personal song
the most personal has to be Let Me Be
Your Whiskey
[Music]
songs actually wrote when I got to
Nashville and so the reason why I'm
sitting here talking about music today
that song is so personal just because we
all use these things to make us feel
better like what if that person
can be that
just don't faint I've had my own
experiences with substance abuse and it
was just a different take on that so
that really meant a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]